the cast of The Brady Bunch because is a
family show remember they reunited to
bring their iconic TV home back to life
with the help of HGTV and et was there
every step of the way so of course only
et was invited back for a special very
Brady Christmas here we you can't have
the angel it's a very Brady Christmas
tree Peter let's see you there
this is the thermic decoration trust
Chris the tarantula nice kill action
decorating a Christmas tree with the
Brady kids well it's a dream come true
for me but a little weird for them now
do you remember what it felt like as a
child when you guys came in and saw the
house decorated it felt off to me it's a
very strange because we were shooting in
the middle of summer so to be in my
pajamas and holding an empty wrapped box
was very odd the holidays are a little
bittersweet for the Brady's the last
time we were with the whole family
including the late Florence Henderson
Robert Reed and an B Davis was in 1988
for the TV reunion a very Brady
Christmas this is a very special
Christmas for us whenever their names
are brought up I think it tooks us all
up a bit and I think all three of them
would be really happy to see us all
together and having each other yeah
now the Brady kids are sharing the love
with their new HGTV special a very Brady
renovation holiday edition decking the
halls of the Brady house replicas and
whipping up a retro 70s holiday feast
with REE Drummond the Pioneer Woman
I'm the unofficial seventh bradykinin
stay there's a turkey and mashed potato
stop it maybe I read the Pioneer Woman I
know somebody tell my wife I'm gonna be
late for dinner
[Music]